let's have a look at one of these tests
that they have that they apply deceiver
a number is prime or not well we're
going to use a fact that I have
mentioned before when talking about
primes and we're going to use firm ours
little theorem it's it's a theorem about
prime numbers and what it says is if you
have another which I'll call a and I'm
going to raise it to a power prime
number so that's called P Prime and I
subtract the original number then I say
that this is divisible by P there we go
so if a number is prime that's always
true for whatever number a you pick so
let's do an example of this let's pick a
prime we know 5 is a prime if this isn't
it yes ok so 5 is a prime so let's use
that and we'll pick some that well let's
see 1 to the power 5 that's going to be
easy 1 to the power 5 minus 1 equals 0
is it divisible by 5 yes we say 0 is
divisible by 5 what about 2 2 to the
power 5 minus 2 so you get 30 hey that's
divisible by 5 as well let's just finish
it off 3 to the power 5 minus 3 that's
240 so these all divisible by 5 4 to the
power 5 minus 4 divisible by 5 again
about five-year well I think this one's
a bit more obvious so that's divisible
by 5 2 and that's always going to be
true if it's if the number is prime this
is what firm are proved in the 17th
century this is absolutely true for all
primes let's try another number I try
another number with you and we try the
number 341 does that pass my test 2 to
the power 341 minus 2 that's my test now
that's going to be a really large number
computers can have methods that make
this easier so that's going to be really
nice on them but I'm not going to write
that down
huge number but I can tell you now that
this number is divisible by the number
we're testing it was 341 thumbs up yeah
great so it's passed the test let's try
another one let's try another test do it
with 3 then we do this 3 2 power 341
minus 3
is this divisible and this is where it
fails the test so this one is not
divisible now if it's not divisible that
tells me it's a composite number there
only needs to be one exception is very
easy to fail this test the more you pass
the more evidence you are that you are
Prime and if you fail at all then you
are composite number only composite
numbers fail if you have a composite
number and it passes the test here this
number two in this case is called a
thermal liar it's not really praised
lying it tells me it's Prime and it's
not naughty this number here three which
actually shows that it was composite
after all it's called a thermal witness
the innocent bystander he goes into a
witness protection program in case two
comes and chases it up after India Brady
you ask a good question though
what would happen if there was a number
that was composite that passed every
test up to the size of the number is it
possible yes it is there are numbers
that will pass this test for every test
you apply those are called Carmichael
numbers they have a name the first
Carmichael number is 561 so what that
means is two to power 561 minus two is
divisible 3 to the 5 6 1-3 that passes
the test
so does 4 and all the way down to 562
502 power 561 and it passes the test
each time must be prime must be prime
must be prime unfortunately it's not 561
is equal to 3 by 11 by 17
those are cool numbers those are really
cool numbers and there are infinitely
many Carmichael numbers the third
Carmichael number is mathematicians
favorite 1729
nice lovely lovely now would you reckon
braids you think this is a good test or
not well till you told me about
Carmichael numbers I thought it was a
good test now I think it's almost
useless if you're looking for perfect
yeah
what is useless yeah well it's not
perfect you're absolutely right so if
you checked all numbers less than 25
billion the number of numbers that would
fail the test if you used a was - all
right if a was - the number of numbers
that fail that particular version of the
test is two thousand one hundred and
eighty three out of twenty five billion
that's just using - so only a small
fraction fail this test or give you
things that you don't want tell you that
you have a prime when you don't have a
prime and you can apply other numbers
anyway so to pass this test actually
quite a high bar so it's a good test so
it's a fairly yeah it's a fairly good
test now there are other tests though
there are better tests that use pretty
much the same idea almost exactly the
same idea so if you understood that
you'll understand the other tests as
well there's one called the Bailey PSW
test pretty much uses the same idea as
that actually uses two tests and
conjunction so you have to pass them
both yes if you pass that test you're
probably a prime in fact though out they
have found no counter example
so anything that passes the test so far
has actually been a prime
there's been no sneaky composite numbers
no counter example - is and they checked
large numbers for this if you do find a
counter example you find a cheeky
composite number that passes the test
the author's originally offered a prize
you could win $30 $30 could be yours now
they would since then the the amount of
the prize it's gone up since then it you
can now win over $600 620 dollars in
fact thank
think that think what you could do with
that money or you could buy yourself a
choc-ice every day every day for a year
twice on Sundays in 2002 they published
or mathematicians published a new method
to test for primes and finally they
found a fast way that was 100 percent
this is now one of the latest things